I think a wife's a wife before she's a
wife
do you understand so there's certain
characteristics you can't meet somebody
and then when they then you show them
who you are because then they're not
going to make you a wife when a man like
you said what you bring to the table
um I do think the women are at the table
if a man reads meets the right woman she
will add value to that man that's
non-tangible and that's just that on
that that's what I believe what value
value to a man that's non-tangible that
means he will become ten times more
valuable than he was before she met like
these characteristics the way he is
certain things that make him a great man
money isn't the only thing that makes
him a great man the right woman makes
you want to do better be better create a
family create a legacy build and create
together do you wanna that's what I
think I think that's a narrative that
we've sold women to make us feel like
we're more valuable than we are like for
example I think most billionaires that
even if they've been married with their
wife for 20 30 years they seem like good
women and they get a divorce like
they're usually fine after they're still
doing great things Jeff Bezos
um same with Microsoft guy
like I don't I don't think I think men
are great and if like a great man's
gonna be a great man regardless if he
has a woman or not it depends on what is
Genghis Khan I think would still
conquered the world even if he didn't
have a Mane I don't know what Einstein
would have still done what he was doing
I didn't say that they wouldn't I just
said if you have the right woman beside
you you're even better that's what I
think well I think sure like I think
it's better to have the right woman but
I don't I don't think they really play a
part in a man's success not not really I
do like I think I think that like
hard-working like uh my dad even though
my mom like helped him build his
business and she did help a lot
um I would still say he would have done
the same thing even without her okay
like because the woman helps navigate a
man's thought process and certain things
if he listens to her as well certain
times that's just me I feel like the man
is the head the woman is the neck and I
feel like there's certain things that a
woman can see in hindsight sometimes
that a man can't see he's more logical
she's more emotional and stuff but I
feel like she instills certain things in
him that he doesn't have and when when
you have the right woman that can help
you to grow with you and build with you
you'll be more of a principal person
more of a principal person listen bro I
just think like this year there is a
certain level of synergy that that is uh
good between you know when you're in a
relationship when you when you're with a
good woman but the woman doesn't
necessarily make him a better man
brother he is what he is
do you know what I'm saying so I I just
I just don't agree with that at all and
then you said people and then also you
said the woman then you also said the
woman is the table how did you come to
that that's what I believe yeah but I
just feel like a woman basically a man
will can become even more greater with a
woman beside him so how does that make
her the table I think if you'd like
specifically describe it like how like a
woman is the person you know like they
say like you give her a house and she
creates a home you give her food she
creates a dinner plate you plant the
seed she gives you a child she's able to
create things out of whatever you give
her do you understand what I'm saying no
she's a support she's not a table she's
that's my opinion it's just no I feel
you you cannot feel that there is any
you know you can say what you think
that's just my opinion what would make
more sense is that you you work together
I think what you're saying sounds more
like your two pieces of the same of a
pie in it like your two sides of a pie
but when you say it's the table it kind
of sounds like the woman is the Bo endo
and the guy's just the The Cameo
character Brothers he does when you say
the table because the table is the the
epicenter of the of everything in that
in that um scenario in that situation
yeah that's where the dinner's on there
we're the ones that have the babies and
everything I just feel like we are the
table
where the table
brings the chairs he brings everything
to us
he bought the food he bought the house
he's protecting you what are you talking
about like I mean like the man built the
house and sure you can add decorations
and make it at home he built the house
like what what can I mean isn't about
food isn't Just About Furniture what can
a man get from a woman that's why so
much people broke up when it was locked
down what they couldn't live in the
house together what kind of my houses
were at homes what can a man get from a
woman that he can't get from a cook a
maid and a hooker
it it if that was I don't I don't know I
don't just think it says clean cut I
don't think it's as as clean cut as that
I just want to cook I just want to do
you understand what I'm saying because
there's energy there there's chemistry
there there's a relationship there yeah
no no no I don't I don't know so you
just think that a man would just just
get a cook just get a cleaner yeah
there's plenty of men that do that and
that's okay I don't know if that's what
I'm not saying that's okay just saying
like if that's that what does a woman
offer like I'm saying that the men are
on the table I don't think the women are
the table I think the men are the table
and the women can come along for the
ride and they can either come or they
can most women don't want to be The
Driver they want to be in the sidecar
breath you know what I'm saying they
want to be in a nice ride they don't
want to be The Driver they don't want to
buy the car and drive the car they want
to be riding shotgun bro how can you be
the table from the Sidecar how can you
be the leader from the sidecar you can't
broth like like you don't even protect
the site like I think
I can understand
what you're saying isn't not the table
in the aspect as we know what the table
is how females say oh I'm the table I
bring everything but it's more of
looking at what does what is the aspect
of a table it's a support so if
say you needed to step on it to do
something better that she's there to
support him she's like she's able to
support
you put so the aspect of a table is to
support whatever you put on it and so if
a man needs to elevate whatever a
woman's there to support him a woman
starts to support whatever is placed
there uh like she said building a family
building
um a home XYZ she's there to support him
in his aspects is that kind of what you
were talking about with the table I kind
of understand it I don't I don't agree
with you see if you're more like the
food on the table that's what I said
because the the table without the table
there which is the the origin without
the table there the foundation there's
you can't you can't put no food on air
you know what I'm saying so the man has
to for instance I'll give you the
example here the man buys the house
because we we said that in our examples
yeah the man buys the house yeah the
woman makes it a home right without the
bricks and the roof and the doors the
bruh you can bring all the decorations
from Ikea or whatever but there's no
house Ralph
so really and truly that's the table
buff
all them all them little things are just
extras all the little mirrors and the
love hope live crap on the wall that's
just that's nothing bro that's nothing
really and truly you can live in an
empty house
you can feel protected in an empty house
you're you're sheltered from the weather
in an empty house the decorations don't
mean [ __ ] they don't mean nothing like I
said I'm not talking just about the
Furnishings like just no but you said it
you made the woman makes the home yeah
it's just to me it doesn't just rely on
the furniture making a home is where
your kids come it's the energy that's in
there do you understand what I'm saying
it's where you feel like you're most
peaceful when you get home do you know
what I'm saying what was the point like
women make a man greater
so is that I feel like it was kind of
every successful man he's a successor is
a strong woman I feel like a man can a
man that finds the right a man who finds
the right woman he lives there's loads
of minerals no no but I I think men are
very successful man is a bunch of women
he's [ __ ] crazy
in the front everywhere and this is this
is coming from like my dad was very
loyal but like no I don't think so like
I just think that men are great like the
the men that are gonna be great and
gonna be ultra productive are gonna do
that regardless of if there's a girl
there or not I don't think the girl
really does [ __ ] I just think those guys
are Workaholics they're usually very
conscientious they're on their path you
can either come or you can go as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible